je pense que la vraie question c'est à
partir de quand des bâtons et à partir
de quand remettons un système donc à
partir de quand considère-t-on que
l'offensé sérieuse peut-on amalgame est
quelqu'un qui se sent offensé avec une
blague une chronique un dessin peut-on
comparer ça à une insulte personnelle
peut-on comparer ça à
des évolutions dans les débats
groupusculaire qui font qu'on se sent
aujourd'hui offensé de choses qui
semblent presque relevé des débats sur
le sexe des anges
moi je pense dernièrement un député qui
a complètement disparu de la circulation
parce qu'il a retweeté un dessin
d'égalité réconciliation
donc est ce que on va atteindre un point
où retweeter quelqu'un ou donner raison
à quelqu'un c'est être assimilé à la
personne en question est donc jusqu'où
va-t-on aller
en fait c'est la question qui
m'intéresse où allons nous poser les
limites
où allons nous commencer à débattre de
ce qui offense an ou deux ce qui doit
appartenir au domaine de l'humour
va-t-on renoncer à l'humour va-t-on
renoncer au débat
et puis en fait je crois que nous sommes
en réalité dans des vraies guerres
intestines
[Musique]